Dragons cast a large shadow over the mythologies
of the world.
Few legendary monsters can compare to these
gigantic beasts.
But what if dragons cast… a slightly smaller
shadow?
What if some dragons weren’t huge monsters,
but strange and secretive creatures evolved
to live hidden lives in the shadows and margins
of the world?
The amazing artist and writer Andy Frazer
imagines a world where dragons are all around
us, from the highest mountains to the deepest
forest.
Concentrated primarily in the author’s homeland
of Wales, these smaller dragons — or ‘Microdragons’
as I call them – make up for their reduced
size with their incredible diversity and ingenious
survival strategies.
The author has released many field guides
on these tiny wonders that explore their evolution,
anatomy, behavior, and habitats in great detail
— which you can find linked below.
So, for this entry into the archive, I’ll
assume the role of a naturalist and observe
some of these creatures out in the field.
Now, let’s set off into the Welsh countryside,
and discover the secret biology of microdragons…
At the start of the expedition, the first
place I look for microdragons is on the low
branches of trees.
Here, a Draco Notophthalmus suns themselves
in the morning light.
While this stunning specimen can fly like
a bird, internally, they have several key
distinctions that make their anatomy unique.
If we examined their skeleton, we’d find
dragon bones are denser than a bird’s, making
them better suited to life on the ground,
where most dragon species spend part of their
time.
In many species the neural spines along the
backbone are also greatly enlarged, forming
obvious spikes.
In the case of Draco Nothophthalmus, these
long spikes can be raised and lowered as a
threat display.
For the Nothophthalmus survives by trying
to appear as dangerous and intimidating as
possible — making loud vocalizations and
threatening postures as I pass by.
From an evolutionary perspective, this approach
has been remarkably successful for a dragon
that, in reality, is a very timid herbivore…
Venturing deeper into the woodland, I find
that no two dragons have the same survival
strategy.
Splashing along the surface of a stream is
a brightly colored Emerald Saeth.
Unlike the Nothophthalmus, this more basal
species is covered in fine, wind-resistant
fibers.
The prehistoric appearance of Emerald Saeth
sheds light into the origins of microdragons.
The distant ancestor of Welsh dragons — the
Dimorphodon Macronyx – branched off from
pterosaurs some 190 million years ago, surviving
the mass extinction that wiped out their more
famous cousins thanks to their diminutive
size and more adaptable nature.
Today, modern dragons have branched off into
ever more specialized sub-species, with the
Emerald Saeth a scavenger of fallen seeds
and berries.
They also have a fondness for playing among
the spray of rivers, although there appears
to be no practical benefit for this — and
is probably done just for fun…
Near a patch of wildflowers, a barely audible
buzzing draws me closer.
Hovering near a carefully chosen flower is
the fascinating Draco Cepediana.
On delicate green and red wings, Draco Cepediana
darts between flowers, feeding on nectar with
the aid of their long, thin tongue.
This behavior closely mirrors that of hummingbirds,
which live a similar high-metabolism lifestyle
feeding on flower nectar.
It might be surprising that such disparate
species would converge on the same strategy,
but there’s evidence to support such an
outcome.
Hummingbird hawk-moths are pollinating insects
that independently became so similar to real
hummingbirds that the two are often mixed
up.
And like all species occupying the hummingbird
niche, the Draco Cepediana performs a vital
role within their local ecosystem — transporting
pollen on the long, red filaments that trail
from their head as they move from flower to
flower.
Pollinating plants is one thing, but among
the branches of holly trees, I find one unusual
specialist has taken their connection with
the foliage to new extremes.
Draco Ilexis is a species whose wings and
body have evolved to resemble the leaves of
holly trees — making them appear like living
plants.
As strange as this specimen might appear,
there is a long precedent for such camouflage
in nature.
Defensive mimicry is relatively common in
the larger animal kingdom, in particular with
regards to plants — as mimicking a plant
is a good way to get a carnivore to ignore
you as a food source.
If a Draco Ilexis is spotted, however, they
have one last defense.
Like the trees they mimic, their wings are
covered in tough, thorn-like spines — which
make Draco Ilexis more trouble than they’re
worth to most predators…
Within the foliage of fruit trees, I discover
another dragon species makes clever use of
plant-mimicry.
The rotund Draco Acidium looks like a round
fruit themselves.
Although they may appear dangerous with their
protruding fangs, this dragon’s large teeth
are only used to pierce the tough outer peels
of the fruits they feed on.
For the Draco Acidium is a frugivore, meaning
their diet consists mainly of raw fruits.
Many animals engage in frugivorous behavior
— and while this might seem like pilfering,
many fruit-producing plants benefit from such
interactions.
Certain frugivores actually assist plants
by dispersing their seeds after digesting
them — a type of interaction known as mutualism.
Which side of the fence the Draco Acidium
falls on is unknown — but it’s certainly
possible these tiny dragons act as natural
gardeners of the fruit groves they call home.
Being slow and flightless, Draco Acidium also
rely on these trees to keep them hidden — although
as a last resort, they also possess a powerful,
acidic bite...
Yet other dragons use camouflage for a more
sinister purpose.
Draco Muscipula possesses one of the most
unusual hunting strategies of any dragon.
Able to remain absolutely motionless for hours
at a time, they hold their wings over their
head and release a pungent odor to attract
potential prey.
Carnivorous plants like Venus flytraps have
a similar strategy, using sweet smelling nectar
to lure in unlucky insects.
And like a flytrap, once the Draco Muscipula’s
prey is within reach, the dragon claps their
specialized wings together, stunning their
prey before dropping them into the waiting
jaws beneath.
For this dragon, patience is more than a virtue…
Yet not all dragons have evolved to blend
in.
Although just a few centimeters long, the
vivid coloration of species like Draco Favilla
mean they can be easily spotted — and that’s
exactly the point.
Like the glaring colors of the poison dart
frog, the Draco Favilla’s coloration is
aposematic, meaning it warns predators the
species isn’t worth attacking.
And while the poison dart frog backs up their
aposematic hue with poison, Draco Favilla’s
color warns of their deadly venom.
Delivered by tiny, sharp-fanged jaws, this
dragon’s venom is potent enough to incapacitate
creatures many times larger than themselves.
I’ll need to watch where I step…
And hidden among the blades of grass, some
dragons are even smaller.
Just two centimeters in length, Draco Coccineus
is perhaps the smallest species of dragon
on the planet.
Indeed, they are so small they stretch our
understanding of what a dragon can be.
Yet remarkably, there is some precedent for
a reptile this size.
Nano-chameleons are a chameleon subspecies
that might be the smallest reptiles on earth
— at roughly the size of a sunflower seed.
At sizes like this, the world can be a daunting
place to navigate.
Luckily, the Draco Coccineus possesses two
hair-like antennae packed with highly sensitive
sense receptors that help them detect potential
threats over long distances.
And so, this insect-sized dragon does quite
well for themselves within their unusual niche…
In other regions, some dragons grow larger.
Around the curve of a woodland stream, I happen
upon a scarcely seen specimen.
A Draco Caudatae glistens in the afternoon
sun, body poised for a quick dive into the
water.
The Caudate is an amphibious hunter, with
webbed toes and a rudder-like tail.
The unusually long and narrow snout of this
dragon contains numerous recurved teeth for
latching onto fish.
Occupying a niche similar to storks or herons,
the Draco Caudatae are natural fishermen.
They are also experts at stealthy movement,
with their silent nature making them difficult
to track.
I’m lucky to be able to observe one…
Upon the rocky coast, some dragons have become
even more specialized aquatic lifeforms.
Perched on a rock in the afternoon sun is
the bizarre Crimson Cimwch.
Possessing a lobster-like tail fluke for paddling
under the frothy waves, this organism fills
a niche one might not expect a dragon to occupy.
The Crimson Cimwch hunts in shallow coastal
waters, feeding on mollusks and small fish.
Behaving like seals or sea lions, they spend
a good amount of time out on the water — surveying
their territory, or just lazing about upon
the rocks.
On the front of their snouts, they possess
curious tentacular appendages that further
separate their appearance from the dragons
of fairytales.
How such a feature first evolved Is a biological
mystery.
I wonder if I’ll find other species with
a similar adaptation…
Below the surface of the freezing waters,
some specimens have given up on land almost
entirely.
The North Nofiwr are sleek, agile aquatic
hunters — using their powerful wings and
broad tail for propulsion.
Their soft, downy feathers keep them warm
in the cold currents.
Feathers on an aquatic animal might seem strange,
but penguins possess feathers that are shorter
and stiffer than those of most birds, keeping
them streamlined in the water.
We can guess that the Nofiwr have taken a
page from the penguins’ book when it comes
to their feather structure.
Like penguins, the North Nofiwr are ungainly
when not in the water, only able to waddle
about.
In their element, however, these torpedo-like
swimmers are something to behold…
Further up the coast, seabirds flap above
the crashing waves.
And hidden among the flock, fearless Seren
y Storms dive close to the raging tide.
These exceptionally rare dragons can be seen
flying high even in the stormiest weather.
With such apparent boldness, it would be easy
to sentimentalize these dragons as courageous.
Yet like seagulls, Seren y Storms are perhaps
closer to pests than they are to adventurers,
and spend much of their time scavenging the
picnic leftovers of tourists.
While valiantly stealing discarded food, Seren
y Storms often release a call that has been
described as a ‘chuckling sound.’
Considering their surprisingly intelligent
nature, it is tempting to think that these
little nuisances are laughing at us…
Heading inland, I notice that high above the
treetops, a flock soars through the open skies.
The pale blue Draco Aerilingii are at first
difficult to spot against the afternoon sky,
but their graceful curved wings and V-shaped
tail give them an unmistakable silhouette.
These graceful creatures are aerial acrobats,
spending much of their time above the canopy,
but able to swoop among the branches in pursuit
of insects.
Certain woodland raptors are able to perform
similar feats of agility, pursuing prey at
top speeds through dense forests without hitting
trees.
But the Draco Aerilingii can best display
their swiftness in the open air, where great
flocks such as this one bank and dive for
no reason beyond their personal enjoyment…
Soon, the night will come to the forest.
In the fading light, I find hidden among the
trunks a primeval dragon that has endured
into the modern day.
Draco Borealis are a species with a downright
prehistoric appearance.
Resembling pterosaurs more than many of the
other dragons I’ve encountered, perhaps
the most distinguishing feature of this species
is their colorful throat-pouch.
Iguanas have similar structures under their
necks that help with thermoregulation.
Yet the pouch of Draco Borealis has a far
stranger function — an air reserve.
This dragon occasionally dives into lakes
to catch fish, and uses their bizarre pouch
to extend their lung-capacity.
The extremes of dragon survival strategies
cannot be underestimated…
With the sun about to set on the far side
of the valley, I come across a particularly
old region of the woodland.
Here, a heavily-built brute with long curved
horns patrols the rotting branches.
This is Draco Babirusis, and they have come
here for a meal.
But it’s not the sort of meal one might
expect of such a beast.
Draco Babirusis is an insectivore, with their
diet composed primarily of ants and termites.
They use their highly specialized head to
dig through rotten bark and leaf litter in
search of their crawling food.
Their top horns also serve as defensive structures
that help Draco Babirusis maintain exclusive
rights to their side of the rotting logs.
With the sun now almost gone, I’ll leave
Draco Babirusis to their supper...
In time, dusk falls upon the forest.
In the low light, I find even more alien-looking
dragon species become active.
Lighting up the dark are the glowing eyes
and tails of Draco Lampyridae.
The function of this natural bioluminescence
isn’t immediately apparent, but we can find
potential clues in the natural world.
The biochemical glow of fireflies is thought
to serve a number of functions — from scaring
off predators to attracting mates.
And since these Draco Lampyridae are in a
pair, I wonder if the glow they give off is
perhaps a method of communication.
If this is indeed the case, I don’t want
to interrupt what seems to be a private conversation...
Amongst the ancient and decaying trees of
the darkest, most inaccessible depths of the
forest, a poorly-understood creature is lurking.
Draco Johansei is scarcely recognizable as
a dragon at a glance — possessing a mass
of highly dexterous tentacles surrounding
their mouth.
While I’ve spotted other species with similar
appendages, Draco Johansei takes these appendages
to a new level.
Like the snout of a star-nosed mole, these
appendages help the species navigate their
environment through tactile input — as the
Draco Johansei are partially sightless.
Yet unlike the star-nosed mole, this dragon
also uses their appendages to ensnare prey.
And while details of diet and behavior remain
largely unknown, signs of aggression tell
me to keep my distance...
In the dark woods, I’ve seen dreamlike specimens,
and beasts that seem to have wandered from
a nightmare.
Yet the last dragon I encounter is both at
once.
Draco Ignisprehendri is an enigmatic omnivore
with a striking appearance.
They appear to be bioluminescent, with a glow
green liquid dripping from their teeth.
Yet Draco Ignisprehendri’s light is actually
borrowed from their primary food source — glow
worms.
These tiny larvae give off a subtle green
glimmer.
And when mixed with Draco Ignisprehendri’s
saliva, the glimmer becomes a hypnotic light
in the dark forest.
Like most species I’ve glimpsed today, Draco
Ignisprehendri doesn’t fit the traditional
myth of the dragon.
Yet they are, undoubtedly, a mesmerizing lifeform…
The dragons we’ve seen today may be smaller
than those of myth and legend, but thanks
to their incredible survival strategies, they
are no less majestic.
And there’s so many more species and biological
details to discover in the incredible volumes
of Andy Frazer.
There are even rumors of older dragons that
blend into the moss and stone and that grow
to colossal sizes — which the author will
address in a new book out later this summer.
If you find these creatures as fascinating
as I do, please follow and support the artist
using the links below — and consider checking
out these books for yourself.
And as always, thanks for watching.
If you enjoyed this entry, please lend your
support and like, subscribe, and hit the notification
icon to stay up to date on all things Curious.
See you in the next video.